combien de temps ça vous prendrai de
lire 20 livres c'est pas la sphère de
cinq minutes en plus des références de
culture générale incontournable ce ne
sont pas des livres 200 pages
et puis si vous lisez pour retenir des
choses alors vous devez prendre des
notes ce qui prend encore plus de temps
vous m'avez compris lire les vingt
ouvrages dont je vous parlais ça serait
très long ça vous prendrai un an je
pense si vous êtes très sérieux donc
abandonné l'idée
n'achetez pas à ces livres ne les ouvre
et pas regarder simplement cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout en prenant des notes vous
allez gagner énormément de temps
regardez cette vidéo suffira pour vous
faire une bonne idée de ce qu'il y a
dans les livres de la liste parce que
j'ai lu et parfois même résumé la
plupart de ses livres
donc j'en comprends bien les idées
essentielles et puis surtout le but ce
n'est pas de vous cultiver mais de
réussir un exercice précis la
dissertation bah oui c'est à ça que vous
vous servir les 20 références
je les ai sélectionné pour ça elle
certains défendre des idées importantes
dans les grands thèmes de culture
générale des concours administratifs
c'est pour ça que ce sont des références
très rentable elles pourront vous servir
dans beaucoup de dissertation alors les
références c'est bien mais c'est la
méthodologie qui fait la différence en
dissertation ça tombe bien j'ai ce qu'il
vous faut un cours gratuit de
méthodologie de la dissertation vous
pouvez le recevoir soit en cliquant sur
le lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite
soit en utilisant celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo inscrivez
vous et vous m'en direz des nouvelles
mon introduction est déjà longue donc
j'abrège je vais bien sûr vous donner la
liste des références mais je vais aussi
préciser l'utilité de chaque référence
pour une dissertation aux concours
administratifs c'est à dire ce que la
référence r a montré dans une
argumentation et puis je résumerais
aussi très rapidement les idées
essentielles de chaque livre
si vous estimez que d'autres références
mérite de figurer dans ma liste ou si
vous avez d'autres idées de liste
n'hésitez pas à me le dire dans les
commentaires
voila voila je vous ai enfin dit tout ce
que je voulais vous dire regardez bien
là
vidéo jusqu'au bout et vous allez gagner
énormément de temps
[Musique]
première référence la république platon
c'est peut-être le livre le plus célèbre
de la philosophie occidentale et c'est
en tout cas la référence la plus
importante de la philosophie politique
plate on imagine une cité utopique dont
le but est de réaliser la justice qu'il
définit comme l'harmonie des partis dans
le tout ça si tu es atteint l'harmonie
sociale grâce à deux facteurs
elle divise tout d'abord les citoyens en
trois catégories les gardiens les
gouvernants les auxiliaires les
guerriers et les producteurs tous les
autres ensuite elle donne le pouvoir à
une élite de philosophes qui vivent
ensemble
selon des principes communiste si vous
voulez en savoir plus allez lire mon
résumé détaillé sur mille idées de
culture générale deuxième référence le
prince machiavel
cet ouvrage est à l'origine de ce qu'on
appelle le machiavélisme l'idée qu'il
faut exercer le pouvoir politique
en excluant les considérations morales
fait machiavel désenchante la politique
en la débarrassant des scrupules
juridiques et moraux qui restreignait
voire paralyser l'action de l'état au
moyen-âge
il rejette tout idéalisme parce qu'ils
pensent que les hommes sont des tyrans
en puissance il ne veut pas faire régner
la justice mais seulement canaliser les
intérêts conflictuels pour qu'ils
s'entre détruisent sans avoir pu
ébranler le pouvoir
cependant le machiavélisme dégénère en
amoralisme le philosophe propose même un
système généralisé d'immoralité et
d'illégalité troisième référence les six
livres de la république jean baud dans
la théorie de l'état de jean bodin est
une des principales sources de la
tradition constitutionnelle française et
les six livres de la république sont un
des premiers ouvrages de la philosophie
politique des temps modernes
le concept le plus important du livre et
la souveraineté de l'état
comment caractériser la souveraineté de
l'état
par les droits régaliens et par la
reconnaissance internationale
pour jean bodin qui défend des
l'absolutisme royal la souveraineté de
l'état doit être absolue elle n'est
soumise à aucune règle ni à aucun
contrat avec le corps social
mais en pratique l'état doit être
hiérarchisées pour la bonne transmission
verticale de l'autorité quatrième
référence léviathan thomass option cet
ouvrage sert à justifier l'octroi d'une
puissance exceptionnelle à l'état obs
fait référence au léviathan un monstre
marin colossal capable d'anéantir le
monde parce qu'il veut que l'état ait
les moyens d'éteindre l'extrême
instabilité de l'état de nature
cet état de nature est une guerre de
tous contre tous où l'homme est un loup
pour l'homme
donc les hommes doivent passer un
contrat pour sortir de cette impasse il
crée ce faisant un état illimitée qui
préserve la civilisation de la violence
originelle 5e référence du contrat
social rousseau celle ouvrage de
référence pour justifier le principe de
souveraineté du peuple
rousseau ils refont la société politique
sur de toutes nouvelles bases dans le
but d'édifier un système de pouvoir
démocratique qui réussissent à garantir
à la fois l'égalité et la liberté des
citoyens son contrat social créé un
corps morale et politique c'est à dire
qu'en s'associant les citoyens forment
un tout qui possède à l'image d'un
individu un mois une vie et une volonté
la volonté générale
en pratique c'est grâce à la loi que le
peuple a le pouvoir
chacun décide en contribuant à élaborer
la loi et chacun reste libre parce qu'il
est soumise à une règle qu'il a lui même
contribué à élaborer 6e référence de
l'esprit des lois
montesquieu comme le précédent cet
ouvrage a jeté les bases philosophiques
de la démocratie moderne ce qui l'a
d'original c'est son pragmatisme
montesquieu réfléchit à l'efficacité des
lois en dehors de l'île
au logis ou de la religion à ses yeux il
faut adapter les lois au régime
politique aux pays et aux peuples
auxquels elle s'applique
l'idée la plus célèbre et la plus
influente du livre et la séparation des
pouvoirs pour empêcher l'arbitraire et
les abus liés à l'exercice de missions
souveraine
il faut séparer est équilibré le
législatif l'exécutif et le judiciaire
mais ces pouvoirs peuvent tout de même
interagir 7e référence de la liberté des
anciens comparée à celle des modernes
benjamin constant cette mémorable
conférence donnée en 1819 est une bonne
référence pour justifier la protection
des libertés individuelles
benjamin constant explique qu'il existe
deux sortes de liberté la liberté des
anciens et la liberté politique dont
jouit l'individu lorsqu'ils participent
à la vie publique
la liberté des modernes en revanche
c'est la liberté civile cas l'individu
de jouir de ses droits et de développer
ses facultés comme bon lui semble tant
qu'il ne nuit pas à autrui
ces deux conceptions sont en tension
notamment lors de la révolution
française où les révolutionnaires ont
voulu substituer la liberté des anciens
à celle des modernes 8e référence de la
démocratie en amérique d'alexis de
tocqueville celle ouvrage de référence
pour parler des caractéristiques de la
société démocratique que tocqueville a
mise en lumière après un voyage de
presque un an aux états unis la première
chose qu'il a frappé c'est à quel point
l'égalité des conditions imprègne les
mentalités il note aussi que la
démocratie américaine donne le pouvoir à
l'opinion publique
la france et les états unis ont là un
point commun l'opinion publique y est le
pouvoir dominant en vertu de quoi la
souveraineté du peuple est une réalité
de chaque jour
cela engendre cependant un grand
conformisme une certaine tyrannie de la
majorité
9e référence qu'est ce qu'une nation
ernest renan cette conférence de 1882
fixe les termes de la conception
française de la nation
renan montre que la nation est une
innovation historique qui repose en
partie sur l'oubli france est par
exemple devenu le nom du pays alors même
qu'ils n'y étaient entrés qu une
imperceptible minorité de francs l'idée
de la race ne permet pas de déterminer
les frontières d'une nation car il
n'existe pas de race pur les bons
critères se sont l'appropriation de la
mémoire collective et le désir de vivre
ensemble
10e référence le savant et le politique
max weber celle ouvrage de référence
pour définir ce qu'est l'action
politique max weber pose d'abord que
l'état est le détenteur du pouvoir
politique dans les sociétés modernes
dans celle ci l'autorité politique et
rationnelle parce qu'elle est fondée sur
la croyance à la légalité des
ordonnances et à la légalité des titres
de ceux qui exercent la domination
le sociologue explique également dans
cet ouvrage qu'il existe deux états
d'esprit différents en politique
soit on agit pour atteindre un certain
résultat c'est l'éthique de
responsabilité soit on agit pour
préserver ces valeurs c'est l'éthique de
conviction
enfin il explique aussi que le
professionnel de la politique vis de la
politique tandis que le militant vie
pour la politique
11e référence l'étrange défaite marc
bloch
ce livre est l'analyse de référence sur
la débâcle française de 1940
pour marc bloch c'est le pays tout
entier qui était malade d'un immobilisme
généralise les élites militaires étaient
les premiers responsables parce qu'elles
ont manqué d'autorité d'organisation et
de capacité d'adaptation à la guerre
moderne mais c'est plus globalement
l'esprit français
cette intelligence nationale dans le
pays est si fier qui est responsable de
la débâcle de 1940
l'historien voit dans les élites
françaises engoncés dans leur esprit de
caste former dès l'enfance au bachotage
au formalisme à la bureaucratie à la
fidélité aux doctrines apprises et à la
référence envers les puissants
il voit dans ces élites françaises
l'incarnation de la paralysie
intellectuels responsables de l'étrange
défaite 12e référence mémoires de guerre
charles de gaulle cette référence est
importante parce qu'elle révèle la
conception de la france du fondateur de
la vème république
il ya d'abord dans cette conception une
dose de messianisme charles de gaulle
est persuadé que la providence vous la
france à la grandeur à un destin hors du
commun dans le succès comme dans l'échec
sur le plan politique il veut que la
nation française soit uni
c'est pourquoi ils se méfient des
intérêts particuliers des partis et des
idéologies
sur le plan géopolitique il veut que la
france soit indépendante ce qui justifie
qu'elle soit flexible pour défendre ses
intérêts 13e référence les deux corps du
roi ernst kantorowicz cette référence
certes a justifié la nécessaire
continuité du pouvoir politique et le
consentement à l'existence de l'état
avec l'image des deux corps du roi
l'historien ernst kantorowicz distingue
d'une part le corps naturel et mortelle
du roi et d'autre part le corps mystique
et immortel qui incarne le royaume tout
entier et en garantit la continuité
politique et spirituel la métaphore a
évolué jusqu'au xiiie siècle où le
pouvoir de l'état s'est
institutionnalisée dans une
administration
l'état devient alors une personne
fictive un corps mystique est universel
et il revendique ce faisant une
permanence jusque là réservé à l'église
et à l' empire romain 14e référence la
crise de la culture
hannah arendt cet ouvrage est la
référence pour expliquer le fait que la
tradition n'a plus pour nous l'autorité
qu'elle avait par le passé
quelles sont les causes de cette
mutation hannah arendt souligne tout
d'abord que les sociétés de consommation
de
transforme la culture en biens de
consommation forcément éphémère
alors que la culture traditionnelle est
par définition durable elle met aussi en
évidence la priorité donnée aux
divertissements qui désacralise l'objet
culturel à ses yeux
nous devons retrouver un rapport
approprié à la culture pour sortir de
l'impasse où nous sommes coincés entre
le passé et l'avenir
15e inférences démocratie et
totalitarisme raymond aron c'est un peu
le manuel de base de la philosophie
politique moderne
raymond aron explique que nous
réfléchissons aujourd'hui à la politique
c'est à dire à l'organisation de la vie
collective
nous y pensons à partir de l'antithèse
entre la démocratie et le totalitarisme
cette antithèse révèle que les deux
critères de choix d'un régime politique
sont la légitimité et l'efficacité
elle met aussi en évidence le problème
de la corruption de l'organisation
sociale soit au niveau des institutions
soit au niveau des mentalités soit
encore au niveau de l'infrastructure
sociale
les deux différences fondamentales entre
la démocratie et le totalitarisme
ce sont que les régimes démocratiques
sont constitutionnels c'est à dire que
des règles cohérentes définissent
l'organisation de la société et qu'ils
sont aussi pluraliste c'est-à-dire
qu'ils admettent le désaccord la
diversité des opinions
16e référence la dynamique de l'occident
norbert elias
cet ouvrage est la référence pour parler
de la jeunesse de l'état en
reconstituant la construction de l'état
absolutiste en france
norbert elias montre que le pouvoir
royal a progressivement conquis des
monopoles les pouvoirs régaliens jusqu'à
la centralisation irrémédiable du
pouvoir dans les mains d'une seule
entité pour monopoliser le pouvoir sur
le territoire
l'état a successivement monopoliser les
ressources de violence les fonctions
j'ai dit
hier et la collecte de l'impôt le
sociologue ajoute que la division du
travail a rendu nécessaire qu'un organe
centralisateur préserve la cohésion
sociale la génèse de l'état est donc lié
à la nécessité d'équilibrer la
concurrence entre les groupes sociaux
17e référence l'ère du vide
gilles lipovetsky cette référence sert à
souligner le malaise des sociétés
contemporaines
gilles lipovetsky montre que
l'exacerbation de l'individualisme longe
les démocraties contemporaines dans un
vide idéologique en raison du
dépérissement des grands projets
collectifs sur le plan psychologique
le problème est que les rapports humains
sont désormais réduits à la séduction
tout le monde devient narcissique
sur le plan culturel les repères et les
limites disparaissent
d'où la qualification d'air du vide pour
l'ipo est ce qu'ils se sont l'humour et
la violence qui comblent le vide
18e référence les lieux de mémoire
pierre nora cette référence sert à
parler de l'incarnation de la mémoire
collective française
pour l'historien de l'académie française
pierre nora la collectivité intègre
certains lieux entre guillemets à sa
mémoire en les réinvestissant de ses
affects entrée dans le dictionnaire en
1993 son concept de lieux de mémoire peu
plus précisément s'appliquer à un
monument une figure nationale un musée
des archives comme un symbole une devise
un évènement ou même une institution en
france par exemple la marseillaise le
panthéon le 14 juillet et le manuel
scolaire le tour de la france par deux
enfants ont pour point commun de donner
une image symbolique et vénérable de la
république nationale avec cet ouvrage de
près de 5000 pages pierre nora a produit
avec une centaine de collaborateurs
heures un véritable inventaire des lieux
qui exprime la mémoire nationale
française 19e référence l'état en france
de 1789 à nos jours pierre rosanvallon
comme son nom l'indiqué ce livre
synthétise l'histoire de l'état français
moderne
l'historien pierre rosanvallon montre
que la construction progressive de cet
état est d'abord un processus de
rationalisation
il a fallu constituer un corps de
fonctionnaires stable et compétent
mettre en place des procédures
régulières de gestion ainsi qu une
hiérarchie claire des responsabilités
c'est aussi un processus de
démocratisation
avec l'installation de gouvernement
représentatif mais l'évolution frappante
est que le champ d'action étatique s'est
accrue l'état français est devenu
l'instituteur du social c'est à dire que
c'est lui qui organise les rapports
entre les hommes
la mutation a abouti après 1945 quand il
est devenu un état providence 20e
référence principes du gouvernement
représentatif
bernard manin ce livre est l'analyse de
référence de la démocratie
représentative
bernard manin rappelle que l'élection
est par nature aristocratique parce
qu'elle favorise la naissance d'une
élite tandis que le tirage au sort et
démocratique parce qu'il donne à tous
les citoyens une même probabilité de
participer à la gestion des affaires
publiques
le philosophe dégage trois idées au type
de gouvernement représentatif le
parlementarisme animé par les notables
la démocratie des partis et enfin la
démocratie du public
caractérisé par le rôle des sondages des
experts en communication l'image
médiatique etc
cette démocratie du public est assez
proche de ce que d'autres appellent la
démocratie continue pour caractériser la
démocratie actuelle
j'en ai fini avec ma liste de 20
références
encore une fois si vous estimez que j'en
ai oublié certaines ou si vous avez
d'autres idées
east n'hésitez pas à me le dire dans les
commentaires parce que ça m'intéresse
vraiment les idées c'est ma passion
après comme je voulais déjà dit c'est la
méthodologie qui fait la différence en
dissertation je vous invite donc encore
une fois vous inscrire à mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation
je vois en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant ou à droite de la
vidéo souhaitent en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette
vidéo
même si la méthodologie c'est plus
important j'espère vraiment que cette
vidéo vous sera utile je suis romain je
suis toujours avec mon fidèle aristote
qui dort là bas et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale ap vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
réussir la dissertation ou concours
administratifs
[Musique]